thank you so much for having me Jared
always a pleasure to be here my name is
Kelly I work at our studio I'm a
solutions engineer there and not here to
talk about the tidy versus cuz that's
not what I do
but I am here to talk about something
that I've been on the road doing for the
past year which is talking to data
scientists about DevOps and I've been
doing this sort of overtly
and covertly sneaking and into my
presentations and I wanted to spend this
last conference of my year reflecting on
what I've seen and heard and talked
about an experienced along the way so
thank you for witnessing my reflections
here but first I want to talk about
solutions engineering cuz a lot of folks
don't know what solutions engineering is
and I want to say right off the bat it's
not dev and it's not really ops so why
am I talking about DevOps well at our
studio we as you probably know build a
lot of open source free open-source
tools but in order to fund all of that
awesome software development we also
provide professional toy so we sell
professional versions of our software to
folks who are interested in having that
sort of license and support from us and
my team solutions engineering that I'm
part of does a lot of work to try to
understand what happens when we bring
data scientists science the data science
workflow and drop it into these various
industries and enterprise environments
and try to solve for those types of
problems that we see there so I get to
be a part of these really cool
conversations and be an advocate for our
customers inside of our studio to
discuss you know like what are we seeing
what can we learn what are the needs and
what are the problems that folks have
when they try to bring our into their
organizations so I want to talk about
what the problems are and number one
still for our and now as we are
embracing Python as well Python is just
getting
legitimacy around the our programming
language so when folks try to bring our
into their organizations generally how
that happens is they will download the
free and open source tools because
they've done that in grad school and now
they're gonna do that inside their
organization and we call that bringing
our in through the backdoor it's a
perfectly fine way to get started using
our inside of your organization but it
can come with challenges especially as
you try to grow your adoption of are
within your organization and help other
folks learn the tool and get the
resources from your organization in
order to support that growth so there
are a lot of challenges here for the
past year folks on my team have been
doing a lot of writing about how to
solve for some of these challenges when
you're legitimizing are we still see a
lot of pushback especially from
higher-level folks in management and
people from IT this tweet one of my
friends from the community put out into
the world sometime last January really
summarized it well for me but we see
these these kinds of comments all the
time like can anybody point me to some
good resources for starting a
conversation with the IT department
about making our and shiny and accepted
part of our software hit so we still see
a lot of struggle with this and that's
the problem that I am really passionate
about helping other people solve now
there are frameworks that developers
have used now for many years to start
conversations with IT and those
frameworks have largely been lumped onto
this this topic or this style of
communication that is called DevOps and
so I wanted to give a really super quick
introduction to what DevOps is by
starting with what DevOps isn't now
these if you have heard of DevOps or
have any exposure to it many folks will
tell you that DevOps is just like a
collection of these crazy tools you've
heard things like CI CD and programmatic
deployment and serverless computing and
and all of these tools I've probably
only heard of like maybe a quarter of
them half of them up there there are
tons of logos and companies who are
interested in getting involved in this
space and they can be really fun to get
into and tinker with so many of my
previous DCR and nyr talks have been
about my experiences tinkering with
these types of tooling and meshing them
with our that's not what I'm here to
talk about today because I want to take
a step back and talk about what DevOps
really is to me and that is a philosophy
DevOps is this philosophy or set of
practices that create new processes for
collaboration between development and
operations or IT teams there is nothing
new in DevOps it came from you know a
rein work around lean manufacturing that
was largely written about and you know
70s and 80s and before that it was just
like a framework for making common-sense
decisions so we are borrowing from these
other industries which is really great
it reminds me of kind of stoic
philosophy that's been around for ages
now but but it is excellent to to think
about these these things and how maybe
as data scientists we can adopt some of
them into our own workflows so here's
the classic diagram that people will
show you when they talk about what
DevOps solves for you have this silo
that developers live in and a silo for
IT and operations folks and what
developers will end up doing I this in
theory is writing these this code
they're developing their software and
then because they live in a silo they're
throwing it over a wall and letting it
land in eyeties lap to handle
so the
year from a cheese perspective is that
they are going to end up with something
that is actually garbage that is now
their problem and and the classic meme
here is like the child who's like
grinning and smiling as a house burns
down behind them your problem now so it
ends with this like vicious cycle of
mutual resentment and distrust which is
which is what is frameworks for
communication and making work more
visible aims to solve for and like I
said I'm really interested because I am
a pattern seeing person to see if we
could take some of these same strategies
and use them in in communicating with IT
as data scientists unfortunately we tend
to have an even worse problem because
the data scientists we bring our code to
IT and what they hear from us is hey I
created this code using a bunch of open
source packages some random person from
the internet created and I built a web
app out of it can you uh take this into
production for me thanks so not only are
we asking them to do the same things
with the same bad behavior as our
developer counterpoints are we're asking
them to do it in using language
frameworks that they are even less
familiar working with so I'm calling
this our super vicious cycle if these
chores I'm going to distrust and and I'm
making light of this but it really does
come down to the fact that like even if
we think that what we're hearing from IT
is unfair and judgmental and not correct
it's important to take a step back and
look at things from their perspective
with a little bit of empathy because we
want to make sure that they know that
we're not trying to make their lives
terrible we're just trying to do our
work and we need to take steps
preemptively to help them understand
that so that we can start building that
trust
so here are the challenges as our users
organizationally we're struggling to
legitimize our itself and then we're
trying to work with these IT teams to
get them on board and they are resistant
to that on the other hand technically we
also have challenges we don't have the
same software development background as
our dev counterparts do we lack that
kind of education and exposure to the
types of processes and tools that
software developers have become
accustomed to so that they can
communicate effectively with IT and
we're not sure how exactly those things
map to what we're doing in data science
for the past year I have been working in
closely with our shiny team and our
solutions engineering team to create
content and resources for bringing shiny
into production so the rest of the talk
will be kind of shiny and production
focused but you know these same concepts
will also translate to just are in
production or are in general and
organizations so the shiny team at our
studio has produced a large number of
packages for the support of bringing
shiny at to production and I want to
talk through some of the shared goals
that they translate to that map to
DevOps principles but first before we
get there I want to talk about leveling
up your own skill sets when it comes to
developing shiny applications so I won't
call anyone out because I actually like
strictly not supposed to but I have seen
many shiny applications across my
computer screen that do not look super
great and I think that's the number one
thing to look at when you are trying to
build that trust and legitimacy within
your organization is you want to produce
something that looks professional that
is professional
and that you've tested and that you
understand the performance ramifications
of so I like to think of like hey it's
it's okay I do this type of development
all the time where I'm prototyping
something iterating really fast and
creating a big mess and I think of that
is like creating the hour-long talk of
data products if you ever given a talk
that's an hour long that's a lot of
space to fill and it can be rambling and
cluttered and there are parts that you
know like really hit great and they're
parts that don't hit it all and what
your goal is when you're moving
something just show other people to put
into production so you're looking to
create the lightening talk of data
products so you want this thing this
five minute talk to be targeted and
elegant and streamlined and optimized
and performant and that's the goal but
we don't give you a lot of information
or structure about ways to iterate in
order to get there until last our studio
conference Joe Chang the CTO of our
studio gave a keynote at our studio conf
calls shiny and production principles
practices and tools and one of the best
like coolest gems that came out of that
talk that I just haven't seen people
embrace or get excited about something
is this performance workflow that he
outlined so we've been the performance
work quote workflow he talks about using
two key packages that shiny team
develops in last year called shiny load
test and profits I just so you know Joe
made a point and telling me when I was
developing the shiny and production
workshop that the thing he thinks is
most important for our development and
shiny development is code profiling if
you're not profiling your code you're
you're doing something wrong at Joe's
eyes I won't put words in his mouth but
but profit is the tool for understanding
what's making your code slow is the most
important thing he thinks trusting your
stinks here or what really gets folks in
trouble so you're using shiny load tests
to determine if your application is fast
enough for production and then if it's
not you're using profits to profile your
code and understand how to make it get
there then in order to make it get there
you're going through this optimization
workflow so he has different steps here
I won't go into them this talk is
available on the our studio resources
webinars page and always will be so
please if there's one piece of homework
or take away from my talk it's to go
watch Joe sock because it's amazing once
you've done this you have this piece of
code or a shiny application that you do
feel proud of that you do think is
performant what's next
this is where we can kind of start
digging into the the DevOps goals here
one of the goals of DevOps is to reduce
the risk of deploying a breaking change
when you're putting code into production
so one of the ways that you can do this
is to start writing tests and we have a
package called shine test that will help
you do this so you've developed this
nice application you want to make sure
that it continues to work into the
future and there are a number of things
that you can do that will break the
application so developing these tests
and a testing framework that you feel
good about using around the app can help
you talk to IT and say like yeah we have
a plan for carrying this application and
making changes and supporting it once we
get it into this deployed state but
there's another piece to this automation
I don't want to remember to run the
testing procedure every time I
definitely don't want to have to hand
that job off to IT and I don't want to
need to communicate with them every time
to make sure that they're okay with me
having make the change and they know
that I've run the test it's a big
communication nightmare so
another one of these DevOps goals is in
general just the improvement of daily
work this quote from Mike Orson really
captures this is like even more
important than daily work is the
improvement of daily work you want to
make sure that your IT folks know that
you're not trying to make their jobs
harder and the way that you can do that
with testing is to automate it so here's
where we do get a little bit into the
Gritty of these tools and there are lots
of different tools they can use to
automate tests in our one of two of the
frameworks that we have just available
as examples with the shiny test and yets
are using git and github and Travis to
automate testing so you can go into the
shiny Testament yets
pull that code off make minimal changes
and be up and running with automated
testing very quickly here's my most
important thing about putting shiny
applications since production if Jose is
prof is mine is getting yourself a
sandbox I think that maybe Joe takes
this for granted that this already
exists but in my experience working with
our customers a lot of them do not have
a place where they can simply test
things push them into a similar
production environment and do things
like user acceptance testing even before
they get to the point of wanting to
deploy things with an IT group so the
shared goal here from DevOps is to
shorten the distance between development
and production by having this
environment where you can sort of
iterate and test your deployments and
make sure things work and like a twin
environment to what your production
environment looks like the example I
have here is a four hour studio konnekt
publishing platform but you can do this
with shiny server open source server Pro
or your docker
craziness that you've put together all
of these things are really good
and map across different tools you don't
have to to fall into step with with what
our resources say they work across many
different tooling sets finally you can
get really deep into DevOps and pull out
some some nifty and cool techniques that
also map to shiny development and this
is one that I played with in two talks
at use our this year or I spoke about
the importance of when you're taking
applications to production to decouple
the idea of a deployment from a release
so in a deployment is anytime you push
code into this environment and that
could be your testing environment or
your production environment but a
release is when that code or those
features are made available to the users
so there are different patterns you can
follow to kind of hide a deployment from
your users and tell you're ready to
release it to them and one of those is
application based release patterns so
for that I explored using feature
toggles within shiny applications to
control some of that and the other is
environmental based lease patterns and
I'll cut to the chase environment really
really release patterns are way easy to
manage in my experience for using shiny
applications but both of these socks are
available as recordings if you're
interested in in really digging digging
into that and there are many other
things that you can pull from DevOps
that that translate and will help you
communicate this DevOps handbook has
been really useful to me and coming up
with ideas and creative ways to talk
about DevOps and to practice putting
things in in different contexts for
people so I highly recommend checking
that out and I want to end by saying
that empathetic communication is very
challenging there are a lot of accounts
that we
work with and in folks who we try to
help that are in really tough really
hard situations and struggling to to
make any any progress at all with
legitimization or bringing their absence
production or creating these
environments that are conducive to
helping their data scientists get the
analytic infrastructure that they need
so from DevOps we say make work visible
to finally shared goals build a
checklist and above all be prepared to
iterate because this is a journey and
you're not going to get the perfect
solution on your first try these things
take time to develop and you should be
prepared to to have little heartache and
as long as you keep a little bit of
empathy along the way hopefully you
should have a good time this this slide
is is what we collected at our first
shiny and production training about what
folks ideas about what production is and
I liked this one that came out in the
middle the most of all someone just
responded to what is production with a
single word credibility and that means a
lot to me I think that really captures
what my goal is and going out into the
community and and speaking with folks
I'm trying to help us all as a community
develop that credibility so that we can
work with other folks inside of our
organizations and you can judge whether
I've done a good job of that here my
last ten talks from the year about shiny
and production and doing DevOps as a
data scientist they're all available on
speaker debt and like Jared mentioned
I'm really trying to get that rad bins
hashtag going I'm part of a big team at
our studio that does solutions
engineering and we all write content
that lives at solutions dot our studio
comm and if you're looking to get in
touch with us community our studio comm
and the rad men's channel there is a
way to do that thank you
[Applause]